well I do have existential worries and
I'm I like I think everybody else am
concerned about death
you know it's it's you know death is in
some ways unacceptable it's it's just an
astonishing fact of our being here that
we that we die but I think worse than
that is that if we if we live long
enough we lose everyone we love in this
world I mean if people die and disappear
and we are we are left with this dark
mystery this is just the sheer not
knowing of what happened to them and
into this void religion comes rushing
with a very consoling story saying
nothing happened to them they're in a
better place and you're going to meet up
with them after you die you're going to
get everything you want after you die
death is an illusion
there's no question that that if you
could believe it that would pay
emotional dividends I mean there's none
other story you can tell somebody who's
just lost her daughter to cancer say to
make her feel good you know it is it is
consoling to believe that the daughter
was just taken up with Jesus and
everyone's going to be reunited in a few
short years there's no replacement for
that there doesn't need to be a
replacement for that I think we have to
be we have to just witness the cost of
that I mean there are many obvious costs
at that way of thinking one is we just
don't teach people how to grieve you
know the Midd religion is they're kind
of the antithesis of teaching your
children how to grieve you tell your
child that your grandma's in heaven and
there's nothing to be sad about that's
religion it would be better to equip
your child for the reality of this life
which is you know we death is death as a
fact and we don't know what happens
after death and I'm not pretending to
know that you get a dial tone after
death I don't know what happens after
the physical brain dies I don't know
what the relationship between
consciousness and the physical world is
I don't think anyone does know now I
think there there are many reasons to be
doubtful of naive conceptions about the
soul and about this idea that you could
just migrate to a better place after
death but I simply don't know about what
I don't know what I believe about death
and I don't think it's necessary to know
in order to live as sanely and ethically
and happily as possible I don't think
you get you don't get anything worth
getting by pretending to know things you
don't